on Tuesday April 4th 2023 Donald Trump
entered a Manhattan courtroom and pled
not guilty to 34 crimes it's one step in
a long process that will likely lead to
the first criminal trial of a former U.S
president Trump acted in unprecedented
ways and now there is an unprecedented
response to how he acted Trump lost the
2020 election and left office in January
of 2021 and since then lawyers have been
Gathering evidence in four separate
criminal investigations they are trying
to figure out if Trump broke the law and
if he did what to do about it
to understand these four different cases
you need to know a little bit about how
criminal investigations in the U.S work
in the first phase investigators gather
evidence they might interview Witnesses
review surveillance footage comb over
Financial records or review texts and
emails they show that evidence to a
randomly selected group of citizens
called a grand jury the grand jury's job
isn't to decide if anyone is innocent or
guilty they just listen to the evidence
and basically decide if it makes sense
if 12 of them think it does they'll
issue an indictment only then can the
prosecutor file charges the accused
complete guilty in which case the whole
thing goes straight to sentencing if
they plead not guilty then the case goes
to trial and a jury hears the evidence
and has to come to a unanimous decision
one way or the other
obviously a simplification and there's a
ton of variations in different states
and jurisdictions but that's the gist so
where do things stand with those four
Trump investigations let's start with
the hush money
the state of New York has officially
charged Trump with falsifying business
records in the first degree in its
statement of facts the prosecutors write
that he repeatedly and fraudulently
falsified New York business records to
conceal criminal conduct that hid
damaging information from the voting
public during the 2016 presidential
election this bank statement from
Trump's former lawyer Michael Cohen
shows that he withdrew funds in October
of 2016. he then used that money to pay
an adult film actress to stay quiet
about an affair that she said she'd had
with Donald Trump a few years earlier a
year later after Trump had won the
presidency he wrote several checks to
reimburse Cohen in his accounting
records Trump designated these as
payments for Legal Services which isn't
exactly accurate this is some of the
evidence that led to Trump's recent
indictment and his not guilty plea in
order to convict Trump of a felony the
district attorney Alvin Bragg yes to
proved not just that he falsified these
records in order to cover up the
payments but he has to prove that he did
so in order to advance or cover up some
other crime but I think that these
particular allegations against Trump are
pretty far afield of the really serious
allegations that justify going after a
former president you know the
allegations that he tried to steal an
election in Georgia the boats are still
being counted CNN has just projected
president-elect Biden the winner in
Georgia I believe that the numbers that
we have presented today are correct
there is a phone call between Donald
Trump and Brad raffensberger the
secretary of state of Georgia the top
elections official in Georgia people of
Georgia are angry the people of the
country are angry and there's nothing
wrong with saying that you know uh that
you've recalculated
you should want to have an accurate
election
and you're a Republican
we believe but we do have an accurate
election
[Music]
you don't have it you don't have
it's in the clouds
who is this I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes if they magically came up with 11
780 Trump votes that didn't actually
exist that would have been enough to
steal the election in Georgia a special
grand jury in Georgia has heard the
evidence and recommended multiple
indictments but we don't know yet if
district attorney Fanny Willis is going
to take things further the Georgia team
isn't the only one trying to figure out
if Trump's Behavior after the election
broke any laws Federal special counsel
Jack Smith's team is looking into
similar questions there's been a lot of
attention on this question of fake
electors the state's electors cast their
votes for whoever won the most votes in
their state if Biden wins the state then
Biden's electors win the state and he
gets that many electoral votes the Trump
team wins t-swing States even tried to
assemble slates of alternative electors
even though Biden won the state they
were asking me to facilitate having the
electors meet
and sign some sort of document these
people were going to in violation of the
lockdown sneak in and stay overnight and
then
allegedly
kind of cast their vote in the Michigan
Capital Security wouldn't let them in so
they signed the document in the basement
of the state's Republican headquarters
then sent it off to D.C Trump's team led
similar efforts in six other states
where Biden won a grand jury in DC has
been hearing evidence in this case for
months but they haven't voted yet but we
appear to be in in the closing stages of
this the same special prosecutor is also
looking into a fourth case against Trump
unprecedented FBI searched on the former
president Trump's Mar-A-Lago have been
raided by the FBI this inventory list
from the raid shows that they found
dozens of documents labeled classified
confidential and top secret there's a
Washington Post report last year that
some of this involved nuclear documents
there has been some reporting that some
of these related to intelligence that
could have exposed certain U.S
informants or sources and that basically
the intelligence community did consider
this really important stuff should not
have been hanging out at Mar alonto
right now a grand jury in DC is still
hearing all this evidence
as president Donald Trump didn't just
say outrageous things he acted in ways
that no president ever had before now
that he's no longer in office it's time
to figure out if any of that
unprecedented Behavior was also illegal
and if it was what to do about it
foreign